robert spencer greece is a moderately
small country and yet over 2 000
incidents of desecration of christian
churches around the same time as illegal
muslim immigration into greece has just
exploded
i mean it's unbelievable and yet greece
continues to let in vast numbers of
unvetted radicals
why
well of course greece is under
tremendous pressure from the european
union to take in the migrants and then
turkey has admittedly explicitly
weaponized the migrant wave in order to
put pressure upon europe and upon greece
its ancient nemesis in particular
so you have these men coming into greece
who
believe that images are an insult to
allah and then they see the greek
orthodox churches that are full of the
holy icons and they think this is an
insult to allah these have to be broken
they see the orthodox churches teaching
the trinity and they believe that is an
insult to allah it says so in the quran
so they desecrate the churches and
nobody in europe nobody in the european
union nobody in the greek leadership for
that matter is discussing the cultural
problems involved in taking in large
numbers of muslim migrants but the
desecration of the large-scale
desecration of churches in greece is an
indication of what that cultural
disruption consists of and it's only
going to get worse